my next guest tonight has been covering
Donald Trump since he began his campaign
for president back in the summer of 2015
now she has written this new book
unbelievable my front row seat to the
crazies campaign in American history
here are just a few of the moments from
that time take a look there's something
happening they're not reporting at Cady
and not reporting it Katie
but there's something happened in
Kennedy she's back there little Katie
she's back there alive
Katie sir she does nothing about my
campaign she says you know things about
my campaign like she's an expert we
don't even let her in we don't talk to
her we don't let people talk to her
because she said you know not a very
good reporter but actually Katy tur what
happened she was so great I just served
back to I gave her a big kiss
really fantastic okay
[Applause]
I don't know that was quite a montage
yeah I don't know what it's like for you
to watch that obviously you were there
for all those moments but the president
of the now President of the United
States is obsessed with you and I'm just
thinking to to be in a giant room at one
of his rallies and have him single you
out and have the whole room boo you how
does it feel it feels a little bit like
this right now yeah really weird right
and uncomfortable right now we're an
uncomfortable okay no and you're being
taunted by an orange-haired for exactly
[Applause]
well at least now there's some laughs
here must have been a strange moment for
you when you first realized that Trump
knew who you were that he was talking
about you it was very eyes he's the
first time the very first time I was in
the physical vicinity of him I didn't
know Donald Trump at all I knew him as
the legendary Donald Donald Trump from
the New York tabloids in New York but
nothing personal I mean I knew him from
The Apprentice that you're fired
yeah but that was it not Donald Trump
the presidential candidate this was a
few days after he announced we're
standing around a backyard pool in New
Hampshire about 200 people were there
not like the 10,000 person rallies or so
that we came to see and I'm just
tweeting what he's saying and he's
talking about Mexico sending rapists
over the border and how the media are a
bunch of liars and how he always gets
standing ovations and then suddenly I
hear Katie are not even paying attention
and I don't look up because obviously
it's not me right
and my producer hard elbows me on the
side and I look up and it is me everyone
the whole backyard is looking at me and
I just yelled back I'm tweeting what
you're saying yeah and he was happy with
that yeah kept going with the speech but
it's so strange as we saw in that
montage and that was just the tip of the
iceberg he couldn't stop he just so many
times would point you out in the crowd
he might be in love with you I don't
know I you know I don't know he you
seemed so flattered listen I was the
first network news reporter to cover him
to take his presidential campaign
seriously and
thought and the first interview that we
did I'm sure he thought that he was
gonna get a very friendly easy interview
I'm I wasn't a political person
I don't know I'm five foot two I'm
relatively young and I don't know what
he was thinking but I didn't back down
and I kept holding up the facts to what
he was saying he didn't often line up
with the facts and he couldn't
intimidate me and he couldn't push me
around so I think that's maybe part of
the reason why we kept hearing little
Katie third-rate reporter you it's got a
ring to it you
you